we've seen that the payoff diagram at
option expiration for owning the stock
plus a put of on that stock at some
strike price that this payoff diagram
will look exactly the same as the payoff
diagram as owning a call option on that
stock at the same strike price as a put
option plus a bond that's going to be
worth the strike price at the time of
expiration one point of clarification
and actually let me just draw that
payoff diagram just so you know what it
looks like so if this is the underlying
stock price stock price and let's just
do the payoff diagram when we look at
the value of the of the portfolio or
your holdings what it looks like is if
this is the strike price over here if
the stock is at the strike stock price
or anything lower you make a fixed value
and anything above that you get some
type of upside so either if you have the
stock or the put you have this type of a
payoff or if you have the call plus the
bond the one point of clarification I
want to make is that you can only say
that this is definitely true for
European for European call options for
European options I should say in general
European call and put options because
only in European options can you know
for certain for for sure that the
options are going to be exercised on the
X or they can only be exercised on the
expiration date if we're dealing with
American options either party could
either the on the put side or the call
side could exercise their options
earlier so it becomes a lot more
complicated so normally when we kind of
deal with the mathematics of options
we're dealing with European options so
even in the example where we did our
put-call parity arbitrage where we were
able to make that free five dollars the
implicit assumption I made is that we
were dealing with European options that
the options could only be exercised at
the expiration date